et ayant presque gâché ma vie.
J'ai fait une recherche inversée sur Google Images :
une fonction de Google qui vous permet de télécharger une image
et cela vous montre où elle est sur internet.
Me voici à 17 ans.
Un selfie innocent pris avant une sortie.
Avant de continuer, je dois souligner
que ce dont je vais parler est affreux et graphique.
Mais il n'y a pas d'échappatoire.
C'est un sujet affreux.
En une fraction de seconde,
mon écran a été inondé de cette image
et des douzaines d'autres images de moi
qui avaient été volées sur mes réseaux sociaux
sur des liens liés à des sites pornographiques.
Sur ces sites, des prédateurs sexuels sans nom et sans visage
avaient publié des commentaires sexuels très explicites à mon sujet
et ce qu'ils aimeraient me faire.
« Couvrir son visage et baiser son corps »,
avait écrit quelqu'un.
On avait également publié mes informations personnelles :
où je vivais, ce que j'étudiais, qui j'étais.
Mais les choses ont empiré.
J'ai vite découvert que ces prédateurs sexuels
avaient trafiqué ou photoshoppé mon visage
sur le corps nu d'actrices adultes en plein rapport sexuel,
sur des photos
où je me faisais éjaculer dessus par deux hommes.
Cela avait été édité pour mettre du sperme sur mon visage.
J'avais été incorporée sur la jaquette d'un DVD porno.
Les contrevenants avaient édité mes images
pour donner l'impression que ma blouse était transparente ou diaphane
et que l'on voit mes mamelons.
Les contrevenants avaient éjaculé sur des images de moi,
avaient pris des photos de leur sperme et de leur pénis sur ces images
et les avaient postées sur des sites pornos.
« Du sperme sur des cochonnes imprimées » appelaient-ils cela.
Vous vous demandez peut-être
quelles sortes d'images j'avais publié sur les réseaux sociaux.
Me voici, à environ 19 ans, à l'hôtel Claremont,
à quelques quartiers de là.
Ils ont superposé ce visage là-dessus.
Les choses ont empiré.
Rien n'était hors limites pour ces prédateurs.
Ils ont même publié une image avec ma petite sœur sur ces sites.
Vous pensez peut-être :
« Vous vous habillez de façon provocante,
même un peu sexuellement suggestive,
peut-être pour attirer l'attention. »
Si le corps d'une femme attire l'attention,
cela ne veut pas dire qu'elle cherche à attirer l'attention.
Comment définir ce qui est provoquant, ce qui est sexuellement suggestif ?
Dans certaines parties du monde, montrer vos chevilles
est signe de promiscuité, est provocateur.
Peu importe ce qu'une femme porte,
cela sera toujours perçu comme plus sexuel que cela ne l'est.
Dans mon cas, je voulais juste me sentir belle et sûre de moi.
Quel est le problème à cela ?
Vous pensez peut-être :
« Ne pouvez-vous pas configurer vos réseaux sociaux pour être privés ? »
Ces contrevenants étaient calculateurs.
Ils ont ajouté mes amis sur les réseaux sociaux
avec de faux profils,
ils ont suivi les photos publiques
des événements et lieux où je me rendais régulièrement.
Mais pourquoi ?
Pourquoi devrait-on se retirer et se cacher
par peur qu'une telle chose puisse arriver ?
Ce que je publie et ce que je porte
n'est pas une invitation à me violer et à m'agresser.
Les seules personnes qui devraient changer leur comportement,
ce sont les contrevenants.
(Applaudissements)
Vous vous demandez peut-être pourquoi moi.
Je ne suis qu'une femme
parmi les milliers et milliers
de femmes ordinaires qui sont en proie
à ces horribles cultures en ligne, sites et fils de discussion de masse
qui sont dédiés à l'exploitation et à la modification à des fins sexuelles
d'images ordinaires de femmes pour en faire du porno.
Pendant que je vous parle,
des femmes qui sont la cible et elles ne le savent même pas.
Au début, j'ai essayé de demander de l'aide.
Je suis allée voir la police,
j'ai même essayé d'engager un détective privé,
mais ils étaient trop chers.
Ils ne pouvaient rien faire.
Que pourriez-vous faire
quand les sites sont hébergés à l'étranger et les contrevenants sont à l'étranger ?
On m'a dit que je devais contacter les sites un par un,
notifier les administrateurs pour que tout soit supprimé.
Comme vous pouvez l'imaginer,
dans un véritable état de peur et de douleur,
je l'ai fait.
J'ai contacté les administrateurs,
demandant à ce qu'ils suppriment le contenu partagé sans consentement.
Cela a parfois été fructueux,
mais j'ai aussi connu des revers majeurs.
Plus je me battais,
plus je découvrais de sites
et, avec le temps, plus mes images étaient vues et partagées
des dizaines de milliers de fois.
Un administrateur m'a répondu qu'il ne supprimerait le site
que si je lui envoyais des photos de moi nue dans les 24 heures.
Cela a duré des années,
je me suis battue contre ces sites louches et répugnants.
Mais je menais une bataille perdue d'avance.
Je ne pouvais plus continuer, pour ma santé mentale.
Mais que pouvais-je faire ?
Peut-être, pensais-je, que si je m'élevais contre cela,
je pourrais réhabiliter mon nom
et je pourrais réécrire mon histoire selon mes propres termes.
Peut-être que si je m'élevais contre cela,
je pourrais sensibiliser les gens à ce sujet.
Peut-être je pourrais même essayer de changer la loi.
Alors c'est ce que j'ai fait.
(Applaudissements)
Je me suis exprimée publiquement à la fin de l'année dernière
et les nouvelles de mon histoire se sont réverbérées à travers le monde.
Mais la réponse était la suivante :
« C'est une salope grosse et moche, c'est une pute. »
« C'est une ordure qui réclame de l'attention. »
« Sois flattée, bébé, c'est un compliment. »
On me blâmait en tant que victime, on disait que j'étais une pute
et on me disait que je méritais ce qui m'était arrivé.
Franchement,
cela a été plus difficile pour moi à endurer
que mes expériences d'exploitation de mes images.
Mais je ne pouvais pas laisser les critiques m'anéantir.
Je savais que ce que les contrevenants avaient fait était mal
et je savais que ce qu'ils faisaient à d'autres était mal.
Alors j'ai rédigé une pétition.
J'ai envoyé de fervents appels au soutien.
Mais cela n'a pas marché.
J'ai eu environ 330 signatures.
Cela était vraiment décourageant.
Mais j'ai ensuite contacté mes représentants étatiques et fédéraux.
On m'a dirigée vers le département du procureur général
de la Nouvelle-Galles du Sud
qui était déjà en train d'ébaucher de nouvelles lois
pour criminaliser la distribution non consentie d'images intimes.
De la violence sexuelle à partir d'images.
Aussi connue sous le nom de pornodivulgation.
Je suis vite devenue une porte-parole,
un visage public pour les nouvelles lois.
Mais je dois souligner
que je ne veux pas, de quelque manière que ce soit,
m'attribuer le mérite de ce changement de loi.
Cela repose sur les experts en cybersécurité,
les chercheurs, le département du procureur général,
tant de gens qui se sont battus durant des années.
La Nouvelle-Galles du Sud a été le premier Etat au monde
à inclure spécifiquement une provision sur la modification d'images.
Une chose qui m'est arrivée,
une chose dont vous n'entendez certainement pas parler souvent.
Le territoire de la capitale australienne a également criminalisé cela,
également avec une provision sur les images modifiées.
L'année prochaine, l'Australie-Occidentale va introduire une nouvelle loi
et, espérons-le, introduire une provision sur les images modifiées
et j'exhorte chaque Etat et chaque pays dans le monde a en faire de même
car, actuellement,
il n'y a pas de justice pour les gens comme moi.
Malgré tout,
malgré la haine et malgré les critiques,
malgré le fait que je n'obtiendrai jamais justice,
car cela m'est arrivé avant ce mouvement de réforme législative,
m'exprimer publiquement a été la meilleure chose que j'ai faite,
car je tiens pour fait que cela a aidé des gens.
Et je souhaite vivre dans un monde
où, peu importe ce que je porte ou ce que je publie,
je mérite toujours d'être traitée avec dignité et respect.
Du respect.
C'est une idée qui mérite d'être partagée.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.